[Musique]
au hockey
bienvenue dans la maison du carton j'en
reçois tous les jours il y en a un peu
beaucoup mais bon c'est comme ça alors
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu un truc super
qu'on va tester dans quelques jours
c'est un énorme carton de dell je vous
dis parce qu'à l'intérieur
car la surprise mon carton del valle sur
le carton un vieux robot chicken qui est
là-dessous j'ai reçu un nouveau truc
aujourd'hui qui me permettrait un peu de
répondre à certaines de vos commentaires
lorsque certains me disaient mais il
faut qu stabilise son image l'image
bouge trop je sais bien qu'en mode
développe déjà ça bouge un peu mais en
plus et j'utilisais ça avec mon gh5
c'est un joe big effet pour un boîtier
de 1 kg maximum sauf que le g h 5 +
micro plus con compagnie tout ce que
vous voulez ça fait beaucoup plus d'un
kilo beaucoup plus tard un peu plus d'un
kilo du coup j'ai eu mme bréguet avec le
joby trois quarts qui lui permet d'avoir
des caméras jusqu'à 3 kg c'est plus
lourde
et à force musclé mais ça va le faire
donc dû courir avoir une image qui
devrait être un peu plus cool qu'il
devrait moins bouger comme ça et avec la
stabilisation optique du gh5 sur cinq
axes fait pas de bêtise normalement ça
devrait faire voilà donc aujourd'hui on
va parler on va parler du rhône or plaît
c'est le nouveau smartphone de honor qui
était présentée la semaine dernière
lorsque j'étais à berlin je voulais déjà
présenté rapidement lors de la prise en
main pour la présentation tout ça ça
fait un petit moment que je teste ce
qu'on appelait les couleurs ça fait un
petit moment que je le teste est juste
là
et franchement je trouve plutôt pas mal
alors c'est choisir une couleur un petit
peu sauf la chine j'ai fait évader
ouvriers il faut changer les couleurs
bleu ciel et ça c'est la couleur lilas
plutôt sympa assez girly mais je m'étais
dit que ce serait cool pour la photo
d'avoir un truc qui fait un peu pourquoi
alors si on leur plaît il ya plein de
belles qualités il a aussi certains
défauts ce qu'on va faire on va le
tester hier on a testé le
l'autre smartphone qui s'adresse au
gamer pour cette rentrée c'est le poke
au fon f12 xiaomi aujourd'hui on teste
le honor play et demain on fait le match
des champions
poco phone gs honneur plaît ça c'est
pour demain comme d'hab je vais pas
faire une chose c'est à vous abonner à
rester connectés donc avant de parler
tout de suite dû au nord plaît je vais
vous faire un jeu vous présenter un
petit produit que j'ai reçues qui a
l'air d'être plutôt cool c'est un casque
à réduction de bruit de la marque les
dix wolf
c'est un tout qui coûte pas très cher et
qui pètent pas mal lorsque les shows
lorsque vous voulez vous trouver un
petit casque à réduction de bruit pas
hyper hyper cher ça peut être l'occasion
alors on va regarder ça ensemble vous
avez un petit étui là c'est un produit
qui coûte pas très cher qui est à 49
dollars
et en plus de ça si vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un petit lien dans la
description vous avez un code de
réduction avec 15% de remise qui fait
que pour tous vous allez la voir un
tarif vraiment qu'à doiron leur charge
ici directement en micro usb vous avez
d'adaptateurs micro usb usb là dans la
petite pochette l'acd petite oreillette
ça ce clip comme ça tout simplement sur
un de vêtements comme vous voulez le
point c'est je sais pas là haut up off
vous avez bouton de volume pour monter
pour le bc vous avez petits boutons ici
là lorsqu'il est blanche depuis ces
blancs à la réduction est activé lorsque
c'est pas à lui mais avec son bruit
n'est pas activé alors c'est pas une
réduction de bruit comme cela qu'est ce
qu'être 320 c'est vraiment une petite
réduction bout et malgré tout c'est pas
mal le cast coûte pas trop cher
lo'jo est propre on a un son qui est
quand même alors il ya la basse c'est
pas un truc de ouf on est plus un peu
dans le médium une fois de plus sony sur
un casque pas très cher mais pour avoir
un petit casque portatif qui fait kit
mains libres en même temps et puis un
petit fonction réduction de bruit c'est
pas mal si vous intéresse je vous ai mis
le code de remise en bas et le lien pour
aller le voir directement dans la
description
bon parlons peu parlons bien on va donc
parler aujourd'hui du honor plaît parce
que c'est un des smartphones de la
rentrée que je trouve en tout cas lors
de la présentation que j'ai vu quand
j'étais à berlin je trouvais vraiment
cool on peut faire plein de choses avec
c'est vraiment un truc est destiné aux
gamers
il ya un partenariat qui est fait avec
audi sport pour vraiment aller dans le
côté puissance performance
c'est marrant parce qu'un parallèle qui
est fait avec le poteau phone qui lui
c'est la formule 1
un partenariat également qui fait avec
pib gpg je pense que vous connaissez
c'est un jeu qui permet de s'affronter à
100 dans une arène jeu super cool et pib
j'ai forcément nécessite un peu de
performance là vous avez un kir et 1970
pour coup il ya ce qu'il faut d'un point
de vue purement esthétique il est bien
cet extraordinaire à l'avant se retrouve
avec une encoche un grand classique une
grande barre noire en bas des bords sur
les côtés ça fonctionne on est dans les
standards actuels
rien bien 20 go à l'arrière non plus si
on veut qu'il soit vraiment top à
l'arrière il ya un modèle spécial player
edition qui existe qui va être soit
rouge soit noir moi je ne l'est pas pour
les avoir il va falloir payer un petit
peu plus cher
donc là on a les modèles un petit peu
plus standard qui existent en bleu en
noir et là c'est le modèle ultra violet
puis bon franchement a le mérite de
changer un peu
c'est pas mal après on retrouve vraiment
design qui a inspiré cette année du de
l'iphone dix double module photo à la
verticale bon ça c'est pas l'iphone 10
me retrouve aussi le capteur d'empreinte
digitale au milieu les écritures sur le
côté ça fait vraiment penser sawai de
toute façon au nord est une marque de
huawei donc c'est pas du tout surprenant
vous avez également le branding au nord
qui est la petite suri ni passion peut
dire ça comme ça en haut et en bas voilà
rebond aussi le petit label c'est eux
qu'il faut mettre mais qui sait pas ce
qu'est le plus joli on retrouve sur le
côté notre bouton de volume de boutons
pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre ici de
l'usb tisser prise jack haut-parleurs
haut parleur mono on en parlera tout à
l'heure vous pouvez mettre soit deux
cartes sim soit une carte sim cartes
micro sd et sur le dessus vous n'avez
absolument rien le design est classique
c'est vrai que vous vu comme ça on
dirait pas forcément un smartphone de
gamer pour avoir vraiment quelque chose
qui ressemble à un smartphone de gamer
il faut aller sur la plage rishon bon de
ce point de vue là c'est vrai qu'il est
bien mais ils cassent pas non plus tu es
pattes à un canard
vous avez un dôme états unis body et le
côté pratique avec se donne le la à la
différence des dos en verre c'est que
vous n'avez absolument pas de traces de
doigts
ça c'est vraiment gros gros point
positif bien sûr pas du tout de recharge
par induction là dessus tout et c'est
pas très grave parce que vous avez de la
fast charge une recharge rapide
directement ici en usb type c où on une
des meilleures vous aller recharger pas
à 100% en tout cas vraiment leur changer
énormément
donc ça c'est déjà bien ala vraiment
vous avez un écran de 6,3 poussée du lcd
cdu
ps vous avez un ratio écran face avant 2
89% une définition de 2340 par 1080
pixels
la densité de pixels du 409 ptp voilà
bon vérité de rentrer d'un côté un peu
trop technique
alors vous avez l'encoche ici forcément
mais l'encoche vous pouvez complètement
est la faire disparaître il faut aller
pour ça dans la partie affichage et dans
la partie en poche vous avez choix de la
cacher vous gardez toujours les petites
informations ici ce qui dans l'absolu
n'est pas n'a donc soit l'encoche soit
pas l'encoche en gros ça vous fait juste
monter le la bande en eau la bande
turquoise sur lui au bon voire moi en
tout cas l'encoche ça me dérange pas
mais je sais qu'il y en a plein qui sont
allergiques en termes de puissance à
l'intérieur vous allez ce qu'il faut
donc c'est un peu l'intérêt de
smartphone vous avez inquiries 1970 il
ya quelques jours lors d'une conférence
à laquelle était présent à berlin l'ifa
richard ue le big boss de huawei nous a
présenté leur nouveau soc c'est le
keirin 980 alors le peering 980 servir à
aller plus loin en termes d'intelligence
artificielle d'optimisation de la
machine optimisation de la batterie ça
va vraiment être l'un des points forts
réussir à détailler complètement à vous
détailler complètement sur une photo au
pixel près donc ça ça va être vraiment
bien mais on en reparlera donc celui ci
c'est la génération d'avant qui
actuellement commercialisés sur le
marché
faut savoir que 1970 est moins puissant
qu'un instant dragonne 845
néanmoins ils marchent quand même plutôt
pas mal vous savoir qu'ici il est
cadencé jusqu'à 2,4 giga hertz la puce
graphique c'est une manie g72 n p 12
vous avez 4 gigas de ram à l'intérieur
et 64 giga de stockage mais surtout le
point fort de ce produit c'est le gpu
turbo le gpu turbo j'ai testé avec le
aux nordistes quand il est sorti
c'est vrai qu'il apporte un vrai regain
de puissance votre smartphone va être
60% plus puissant que si vous n'aviez
pas le gpu turbo et il va consommer 30 %
de batterie en moins donc l'intérêt du
gpu turbo c'est une optimisation
logiciel que paramètres de tirer le
meilleur parti de votre bécane ici un
kirin dans 70 donc ça c'est vraiment
point qui est excellent et que ce soit
en terme de game in en termes
d'utilisation classique pour pouvoir
aller d'une application à l'autre sur
utilisation standard au quotidien ça
permet d'avoir quelque chose de beaucoup
plus fluide et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant c'est ce qui était mis en
avant lors de la présentation c'était de
dire que au final cette machine qui
coûte 360 euros
à peu près et au final plus puissant
qu'à samsung galaxy s 9 plus coûte
beaucoup plus cher en terme de
performance j'y crois clairement un
trait ya des choses qui sont vraiment
différentes notamment au niveau de
l'appareil photo on n'est pas du tout
sur la caméra du s9 plus donc bon y a
pas que ça qui fait la différence
ça on va détailler dans quelques
instants moi je sais pas du tout à un
core gamer donc je suis plutôt un tel
voeu le gamer sous pas
exceptionnellement bon néanmoins je dois
reconnaître que je l' expérience
extrêmement fluide d'excellents cpu bg
ça m'a tout de suite proposé la qualité
élevée donc ça veut dire tout de suite
derrière et de la performance ça c'est
un point qui est très très cool c'est
extrêmement fluide pbg tour extrêmement
bien là dessus ce qui est globalement
pas surprenant s'allumant pas de sava
mec ça c'est mon coéquipier
ouais j'ai fait plusieurs parties ça se
passe plutôt bien c'est vraiment
vraiment une très très belle expérience
donc en terme de jeu pas de là tant ce
soit sur pib g ou sur d'autres jeux ça
c'est franchement plutôt cool maintenant
il ya un truc que je regrette un peu
c'est à dire que vous jouez vous avez eu
de la puissance ça va plutôt bien il
réagit extrêmement bien
de ce point de vue là c'est cool par
contre ce qui est vraiment frustrant et
notamment par rapport au propofol mais
s'en va revoir le comparatif demain
c'est à dire que vous avez simplement un
haut parleur mono ici pas du tout des
haut parleurs stéréo et pour des
sessions de jeu sans casque c'est un
petit peu frustrant c'est vraiment un
peu le problème c'est qu'on est vraiment
situé dans le même prix mais il se dit
demain on va faire le comparatif
pourquoi fois défunt vs au nord plaide
donc on va durer un petit peu les points
qui sont plutôt forme d'un côté plutôt
faible de l'autre on va détailler
ça c'est un peu ce qui m'embête à côté
de ça il a vraiment un point qui est
excellent avec le casque c'est à dire
que avec le casque il marche très très
bien
vous avez la prise qui se trouve en bas
et lorsque vous le branchez vous allez
activer une fonction qui va vous
permettre de choisir votre mode de
spatialisation pour pouvoir avoir une
immersion supplémentaire dans le jeu
alors on est néanmoins sûre de la stéréo
mais lorsque vous jouez un jeu comme pdg
pour savoir où situer votre ennemi si
l'arrière droite à l'arrière gauche
si les ailes avant nos côtés sessad ou
est-ce que ça tire c'est vraiment bien
il ya différentes options et ça pour le
coup je dois reconnaître que c'est
vraiment intéressant je vais dans les
paramètres audio je vais dans son j'ai
ici une petite case qui n'est pas du
tout accessible qui n'est accessible que
lorsque
j'ai branché mon casque effets sonores
weston et ça c'est plutôt cool là j'ai
plusieurs modes de lecture automatique
audio 3d naturel standard ça vous permet
de choisir un petit peu l'effet que vous
voulez like l'effet 3d vous avez simuler
la profondeur de champ sonore 3d pour
une écoute immersive ça pour des dimming
c'est vachement bien naturel c'est la
production authentique du son ça va être
mieux lorsque vous allez écouter de la
musique
ouf que l'audio 3d c'est vraiment génial
pour jouer à des jeux comme un pib j'ai
très clairement et là vous choisissez
votre effet 3d rapprocher de fass grand
élargi - les migrants je trouve ça bien
et c'est vrai qu'à sensation est quand
même plutôt pas mal un petit côté un peu
plus immersif lorsque vous allez jouer
alors je vous le dis c'est vraiment pour
une idée de spatialisation on n'a pas
d'effets 7.07 point où ce que vous
voulez c'est juste pour la
spatialisation va justement parce qu'on
parle de dieu je vais vous dire moi je
trouve bleus sont bien mes moyens je
trouve bien avec le casque je le trouve
assez standard ce qui n'a pas de casque
du fait du haut parleur mono
après en terme de puissance on a aussi
ce qu'il faut il ya de la puissance
regarder je vais vous mettre une vidéo
j'utilise beaucoup pour pouvoir comparer
c'est ma vidéo du dernier hellfest
[Musique]
lâchés tous à fond il y a du volume mais
c'est pas non plus complètement dingue
la technique a pour gagner en volume
vous avez votre haut parleurs qui est là
vous mettez votre dans le creux de votre
main comme ça et là tout de suite cette
race davantage regarder c'est comme ça
dans l'est
en fait vous allez vraiment diriger le
son là vous voulez donc en mettant comme
sa leçon on va venir plus sur vous et ça
vous permettra de profiter d'un peu plus
de volume sonore pour avoir la meilleure
expérience il faut mettre le casque est
là tout de suite
il prend une autre dimension et surtout
avec les réglages que je vous ai montré
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que c'est
complètement autre chose ça va mieux là
des gens et en plus de ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est le fait de pouvoir
effectivement réglés
la spatialisation pour avoir un son soit
plus naturel soit un peu plus large et
ça c'est cool donc là je vais tester
avec le sont vraiment spécialisés langue
comme je le ferais pour jouer à un jeu
vidéo type pbg maintenant je vais me
caler pour mieux le mettre sur un effet
un peu plus naturel pour alors vraiment
retrouver le son que je et tout de suite
ça marche aussi super bien allez hop on
y retourne youtube lecture là c'est très
bien c'est fort mais pour moi la qualité
sonore là elle est vachement mieux vous
parle donc de performance avec le kirin
270 4 gigas de ram avec le gpu turbo sur
tout mais je vous parle aussi
d'optimisation de batterie avec une
batterie de 3750 milliampères heures
vous permet de durer plus d'une journée
en utilisation lors des différentes
phases de test changement à pib les
jeunes qu'au temps de la musique en
vendant des vidéos que ce soit sur
netflix sur youtube en surf en
partageant ci et ça franchement une
journée une grosse journée une journée
et demie sans problème l'autonomie est
franchement là elle est au rendez vous
et en plus ce qui est bien par rapport à
des batteries de 3500 millions terreur
elle est optimisée de par le fait du gpu
turbo c'est vraiment un excellent point
et c'est là où on voit toute
l'innovation de ses de ce gpu turbo
c'est pouvoir vraiment grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle aussi plus
logiciel d'aller plus loin et vous allez
voir ça va être la grande grande grande
grand focus qui va être fait en 2019
avec des queyries 980 avec destin dragon
850 550 je sais pas quel nom il aura qui
aura le même nom que pour la partie pc
856 qui passera entre 55 le focus va
vraiment être fait sur l'optimisation
avec de l'intelligence artificielle pour
gagner en puissance et pour gagner
surtout en autonomie donc une batterie
de 3750 millions perdre là-dessus avec
de l'intelligence artificielle le gpu
turbo ça marche parfaitement bien point
qui est plutôt cool vous avez capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est
extrêmement réactive d'arrière garde et
mon dos a derrière attention ça
déverrouille très rapidement ça marche
mais vous avez aussi de la
reconnaissance de visage c'est
infectiologues reconnaissance faciale
voilà glisser pour ouvrir c'est parti ça
marche plutôt bien
donc vous pouvez faire le chinois
préfèrent un code vous avez pas mal de
possibilités
c'est pas de la reconnaissance faciale
en trois dimensions sa douce kanpai
rhissa reconnaît uniquement votre visage
mais pour déverrouiller d'une façon
standard ça marche plutôt bien
la main vous séduit par les services
secrets qu'ils aient besoin de vous
piquer votre téléphone et le
déverrouiller sinon pour monsieur et
madame tout le monde ça ira parfaitement
bien et en termes de photos vidéos vous
avez ici un double module caméra située
à l'arrière 16 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.2 c'est un appareil
photo qui est boosté à l'intelligence
artificielle comme s'est parfaitement
bien le faire au nord sur ce type au
logis modèle est également au wawel est
dire ouais mais également huawei vous
avez 22 scènes qui sont reconnus grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle pour
complètement à les optimiser votre rendu
photo vous avez bien évidemment le mode
portrait vous avez la stabilisation gros
vous avez de l'intelligence artificielle
pour venir complètement optimiser votre
bécane à l'avant vous avez une caméra de
16 mégapixels également à une ouverture
de f 2.0 une reconnaissance faciale en
trois dimensions alors ce n'est pas du
fait que cela dit attention vous pouvez
faire bien sûr des effets boké vous avez
trois déportés lightning pouvait filmer
en 4k à l'avant comme à l'arrière
lorsque vous êtes dans l'appareil photo
vous avez plusieurs possibilités vous
avez bien évidemment le mode photo le
mode portrait l'objectif avec des
filtres à air je vais vous montrer c'est
assez marrant le mot d'ouverture c'est
pas une nouveauté mais c'est plutôt cool
aussi
on a bien sûr d'eux
vidéo et puis ensuite vous avez le mode
pro vous pouvez prendre des photos en
mode raw ça c'est plutôt cool la partie
clichés une option qui est vraiment mis
en avant des scans de documents de qr
codes mode artistes panorama 3d bon a
timely stan l'aps panorama 3d creator
soit c'est plutôt rigolo il vous le
voyez si vous avez le bouton
intelligence artificielle qui va être
activée ou désactivée pour la
reconnaissance de scène pour tout ça
tout ça
là vous avez up la fonction image
dynamique activée mais pour moi le côté
un petit peu rigolo ce sont les
objectifs avec filtre à air up vers des
poils alors vous avez de tous
y a un truc un peu kitsch des trucs un
peu plus classique qui sont quand même
assez marrant voilà des arrière-plans
comme ça c'est rigolo et les trucs so
girly quand la main alors que c'est un
truc de gaming c'est un petit peu girl i
mais bon on va les notes
voilà l'état a dit halloween les petites
lunettes ça marche toujours bien la
détection de visages se fait extrêmement
bien briller je suis un peu derrière mon
gauthier mais malgré tout ça marche
c'est plutôt cool
l'arrière-plan ça reconnaît sa détour
patron trop mal ça s'est une fois de
plus grâce intelligence artificielle à
sa porte et au tessin alors on va y
retourner pour regarder les objets 3d
peut poser des objets 3d ici là là on a
ici j'ai un petit objet 3d
c'est assez rigolo mais celle des petits
exemples de ce qu'on peut faire grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle pourquoi je
vous emmène à la maison bale est
typiquement ce site prendre en photo une
plante
il a reconnu que c'était une plante ça
marche plutôt bien on la voyait
typiquement vous avez les guitares donc
moi de mon côté c'est quand même assez
sombre sur l'appareil s'est tout de
suite beaucoup plus clair beaucoup plus
de luminosité des couleurs qui sont
beaucoup plus saturés beaucoup plus
vivre je le filme en conditions de
faible luminosité dans la salle de bain
alors y'a pas beaucoup de lumière ça
vous le voyez directement mais alors il
ya ça rajoute forcément du bruit à
l'image ça c'est un grand grand
classique malade et maintenant sur les
caméras avant ce que ça peut dire la
voyez sur la caméra sur les caméras
avant l'ag une source de lumière de ce
côté là tout de suite ça rajoute c'est
beaucoup plus lumineuse et lorsque je
viens comme ça je suis à contre jour
mais malgré tout sa vache ça me fait un
traitement d'image
qu'ils aient beaucoup de bruit ça me
fait un traitement d'image qui est
comment dire un peu lisse et ça le fait
une peau un peu lisse et ça me fait avec
vachement de vachement de bruit c'est
hyper particulier on voit que le
logiciel a su essaye vraiment s'en
sortir pour tirer le meilleur de l'image
avec ce qu'il est capable de faire alors
à l'avant on a du f2 point zéro à
l'arrière du f 2.2 c'est très marrant
parce que c'est beaucoup plus lumineux
comme ça en terme de cette fille alors
que là je suis complètement contre jour
là ce que je trouve vraiment putsch en
train de le film à l'extérieur c'est la
stabilisation parce que là chez soi la
caméra de celle ci je trouve vraiment
hyper stabiliser alors moi qui ai
toujours temps d'en savoir un peu la
tremblote là ça bouge pas mais ça me
donnait une image qui est complètement
autres c'est complètement clean alors là
forcément je ne me posais je trouve que
le rendu pas mal ça fonctionne bien
alors bon c'est quand même un peu cheap
et comme un genre il serait caméra un
jour mais moi ce qui me surprend
toujours esquina personnes ça c'est
grâce au gpu turbo c'est la
stabilisation qui est vraiment vraiment
vraiment top sur la caméra selphy
maintenant on va tester de l'autre côté
sur la caméra arrière et c'est
exactement la même chose sur la caméra
arrière si vous regardez là je bouge un
peu
c'est exprès et c'est quand même hyper
hyper stabilisait tout ça vraiment
vraiment vraiment bien je trouve que là
dessus on aura fait un vrai vrai vrai
super boulot le gp turbo entend vraiment
quelque chose en plus
c'est vraiment pas un gadget donc ça
c'est vraiment un point qui est très
positif
c'est un mode portrait êtres qui sont
assez marrant à faire vous avez ici up
différents éclairages de la fiq vous
voyez bien vous avez différents
éclairages donc lie absolument aucun
éclairage l'a ensuite je vais arriver à
l'éclairage double éclairage papillon
l'éclairage scinder l'éclairage
classique et voulait retrouver bien
évidemment là alors bon là il ya un côté
qui est un petit peu qui peu cramé un
côté effectivement de relief
il ya c'est à la fois pas mal après j'en
étais là ce qui est un petit peu fort
mais ça fait vraiment ressortir
et là ça me fait des cernes à mon dieu
on dirait que j'ai pris dix ans dans la
tête de coûts ou ce coup là ça me détour
bon après c'est compliqué parce que moi
en plus comme j'ai les cheveux gris
c'est compliqué pour le détour et voyez
quelque chose de très net par rapport
aux fonds ou là ça va être blanc peu
plus gris là c'est pas hyper évident je
trouve qu néanmoins il s'en sort pas
trop mal il fait une tête tous l'hymne
why not
un là ça me fait une tête de meurtrier
je vais peur mais bon voilà non en tout
cas bon je pense que ça il faut vraiment
le voir en fonction de l'endroit où vous
êtes en fonction de votre tête en
fonction de pas mal de choses je trouve
que c'est marrant ouais ça va dans le
bon sens où c'est pas idéal
là ça m'a fait des cernes sous les yeux
c'est ouf le truc sais pas si vous voyez
là j'ai l'impression d'avoir pris un
cocard
du point de vue le reste d'une surcouche
à mu 8 points 2 qui tourne sur un oreo
8.1 alors si vous l'avez habitude de
cette surcouche là vous savez vous
n'avez pas de tiroirs d'applications
directement en bas
si vous le voulez il faut venir l'activé
directement dans vos pas m j'ai pas
d'info sur la migration sur android 9
paille pour le moment bon la version
fonctionne bien et me 8 points 2 rien
n'a rien à lui reprocher contrepoint
petit peu de regrets sont se produit ils
ont absolument pas parler de
certification donc ce produit a pour
l'instant selon moi et selon ce que j'ai
vu absolument pas de certification ip68
ip67 donc éviter de le jeter dans l'eau
il n'est pas étanche normalement à l'eau
et à la poussière alors je pense que
s'ils croisent de la poussière il va pas
tomber en panne s'y croisent un peu
d'eau n'a pas non plus je t'apprends les
murs ne devrait pas lui poser trop de
problèmes mais on n'a pas un produit qui
à cette certification il est disponible
dès maintenant s'il vous intéresse vous
pouvez le trouver en quelques gigas de
ram 64 giga de stockage 329 euros et de
la paix aurait dit choqué à 349 euros
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse je vous
ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description on parle on parle mais il
faut voir ce qui est intéressant tout
cas avec ce produit c'est que
on voit que au nord sort une nouvelle
gamme ils ont effectivement la gamme
view disque est sorti en début d'année
avec ce fameux view disque est la gamme
numérotée au nord 8 au nord 9 aux
nordistes avec les déclinaisons x à
voilà tout ça vous avez les modèles
light également comme le au nord 9 lite
et lagacé toute nouvelle gamme qui vient
d'arriver la gamme pour gamer c'est la
gamme au nord plaît et ça c'est le tout
premier du genre
donc c'est vraiment intéressant et ce
qu'on voit à travers tout ça c'est que
au nord cherche pas vraiment à se
diversifier avec une stratégie de marque
vous avez vraiment la stratégie de
marque pas pyramidale mais avec huawei
au dessus et les innovations majeures et
des produits haut de gamme des produits
plus milieu de gamme avec les modèles de
chez au nord plus destiné à un public
jeune et un public plutôt gamer on le
voit avec le nordiste aux nordistes qui
est vraiment bon pour moi un produit qui
est vraiment magnifique le dos et hop il
est vraiment fort j'ai pas eu à encenser
mais je trouve vraiment très très bien
je trouve celui là plutôt pas mal
je trouve bien mais je lui reproche
certaines choses qui n'ont pas de
certification c'est un petit peu
embêtant pour un produit de gamer or le
modèle player edition je trouve que ce
modèle là il devrait avoir un look plus
petits pays devrait aller un peu plus
loin il devrait y aura quelque chose
dans un petit peu plus dynamique
il est bien on peut pas dire qu'il ait
pas joli il est dans les standards
actuels
mais il révolutionne pas l'histoire et
pour un produit destiné aux gamers
il lui manque un peu de caractère après
l'écran fonctionne plutôt bien je
reproche qui pas de haut parleurs stéréo
pour une expérience gaming or casque je
crois que c'est pour une question de
coût de production néanmoins lorsque
vous allez sur le poteau phone vous
l'avez c'est un petit peu le point de
regret là dessus mais dans l'ensemble je
trouve quand même plutôt pas mal assez
intéressant alors si vous aimez la
marque au nord si vous jouez à des jeux
si vous êtes un gamer vous pouvez y
aller et je vous dis dès demain on va
faire le comparatif entre d'un côté le
aux normes played de l'autre côté le
poke au fun donc on va regarder un petit
peu ça c'est un peu le match des titans
1 pour voir lequel sera numéro un dans
la catégorie gaming pour les produits
qui sont quasiment au même prix aux
environs des 3 150 euros donc je vous
invite bien évidemment à vous abonner
à rester connectés parce qu'on va parler
de tout ça et puis une fois de plus
resté avec moi parce que vous allez voir
qui va se passer plein plein plein plein
plein plein de choses demain il ya le
comparatif en toile de produits et après
demain vous emmène avec moi on va vivre
la dolce vita on part à milan on va
aller manger des tagliatelles des
carbonara des pizzas des macaronis
pepperoni et tous les maux qui finissent
en rit et on va y avoir aussi shiomi
voyez shiomi cp italien mais ça finit en
eau et sa hargne pour ça c'est plutôt
cool
à demain
[Musique]
où
on
[Musique]